come on come on give me a little more
whoa just another Tuesday training a
smoking hottie man I love being a
personal trainer
hey big stud put your camera away so you
can focus on me she stares at Sammy's
rippling muscles what as what got cut
you'll read the stage directions you
moron
all right we're filling for real this
time no more screw-ups you're crazy but
this job and you're smoking hot damn you
guys get away from me today has been a
nightmare I couldn't even get a courtesy
laugh every single person out there is
just an uptight asshole sounds like
you're not respecting your own it's true
my dad's gonna die that's all because
I'm the least funny stupidest loser ia's
guy in the world guy they love you yes
they do
trillions cable of God a galactic
offensive is a reason why